我開始吧 那個謝謝大家
我覺得先把那個我最近梳理一下市場現在整體的情況
然後對應一下2024年年底的時候我們的現在狀態
就是當時我們一直在說tell risk嘛
然後現在相對來說我比較stay put沒怎麼動
然後我會說一下就是我對現在這兩個市場整個狀態的一個理解
我覺得兩個是現在是不同的狀態
現在並不是完全說我們會出現tell risk
出現tell risk你應該持有一定的倉位
然後買一些put來防止這樣的tell risk
但是現在狀態可能就是不會像2024年一樣有一個很大的風險
有很多的風險都已經被pressing了
但是現在發生就是下跌或者是發生那個
主要發生下跌或者價值從調整的這個全球範圍
出現價值調整的概率會變得更大
就是它的概率會更大
但深度和速度不一樣那麼的快
就是這個是我對整個市場的一個了解
就我待會整體說一下吧
今天講幾個事情
一個我來分享一下就是我對這個市場現在狀態的一個分析
另外就是週末有很多人在說美國被downgrade的事情
就是不是tax bill吧我這也沒有寫
但是美國被那個評級機構給downgrade
所以母帝downgrade美國然後對美國有什麼樣的影響
因為中國有很多對沖基金的朋友
大家一起討論過這個事情
特別是中文的對沖基金
其實他們對於美國就是覺得美元霸權要結束了
然後覺得美國大量的債務
我說一下我對美國downgrade和美國債務的一些了解
然後其實之前我們說的更多的是美元的基礎
為什麼美元和美債不會出問題
那麼我今天可能著重說一下
就是大家一直講到的美國今年有9萬億的債
或者一直說美國就有個我們叫做majority war
majority war就是眼前有很多債務要到期
那麼這個債務要到期會不會影響美國信用
包括目的對於美國債務的downgrade
有沒有什麼就是就是有沒有什麼stand
有沒有什麼對市場有沒有影響
然後這個理論充不充分
首先說一下我對市場一個理解
就是我做了一個簡單表格也沒有做美化
其實這樣子就是我們現在整體看到
我們前幾個星期分享了挺多的
包括CTA的position
其實我覺得主要來自於三方面
就是我們先說這個格子就是market position
包括CTA的position
包括deadase position
deadase就是投行
然後包括Hedge fund position
在2024年年底的時候都非常非常重
包括我們會當時會看到
我這裡可能我這個PVP換過了
我前面幾個圖片我刪掉了
所以如果你放開看一下
我前幾個星期的視頻的話
我們看到CTA其實在2024年年底的時候
基本上80%到90%
那個rounding是很高很高的
所以大概比現在多250個別鏈
那個CTA不光是CTA
包括vocontrol
這些我們叫systematic trading position
是很高的
然後包括deadase和那個投行的客戶
Hedge fund基本上全在做多
特別是特朗普當選以後
覺得這個市場會變很好
特朗普是pro business
所以他會那個會減稅
會做各種各樣的事情
所以當時的頭寸很重
在頭寸很重的
我們不能光說有多少企業
在頭寸很重的時候
你記得我們當時講過幾個事情
就是我們被認為市場在石頭裏面擠油
石頭裏擠油意思就是所有能夠套的spread
我們不管是那個carry trade的套的spread
能夠套的力全部套完
那我們會看到impliable和realizable之間的差別很小
而且整個vix很低
然後買option積極便宜那個是2024年
然後2024年年底
然後加上我們看到 that risk premium
activity risk premium幾乎是已經達到底了
達到0了
跟債券之間基本上已經到0了
然後我們會看到那個cdx
然後和那個包括investment grade
包括那個high yield
它的那個所有cdx
包括不光是美國
包括atrex在歐洲
都這個樣子
它的那個quad spread非常非常窄
quad spread窄
就意思我願意付很少很少的代價
去買一張信用展
而不是買國債對吧
所以認為所有公司都不會破產
那麼在這種情況下
我們認為市場的頭寸是到底的
那到底會不會繼續漲的
會
因為當時foundamental很好
就是我們會看到通脹很低
然後我們看到經濟增長很好
然後估值雖然很高
那個market position很重
但是問題是
只要foundamental好
它確實可以繼續漲
但是你不確定川普會搞什麼名堂
所以它確實搞了一下
那麼這個時候市場
如果對於這樣的預期的下調
它是非常急速的
就是我們會看到
在今年4月份的時候這種
一下子跌很多
然後因為當時的市場
不確定特朗普的政策會怎麼樣
也就是說我們看到的
tariff的政策是什麼
是從2%
就是原來的
effective tariff大概是2%
直接升到了25
就預期中間有過程
不是一下升到25
但是在它那個
reversing day的時候
這個公佈的東西其實就是25
那麼然後最近從25降到了12
所以在25的時候
市場不確定
我們叫做left side有多大
就是這個left side就是
市場到底
川普到底這個政策會搞到哪個地方去
你確實也不知道
沒有人知道的
除了它身邊人知道
可以去做內幕
沒有內幕的人是不清楚這個情況
所以pricing了很大的一個
我們left side
tariff
然後這個tariff又發生了
所以當它下跌的時候
整個市場的position很重
然後fundamental
從strong變成了極長
然後variation很高
然後一下子的時候差下去
其實即使在殺到最深的時候
我不覺得估值還很低
就是估值還是很高的
就是即使在殺到最深的時候
當然有很多股票
包括那個特別是半老體中間
很多股票估值確實很低
科技股確實已經估值已經達到
我覺得就是很低了
當時很低
但是整體你看S&P的話
看指數的話
它估值並沒有算很低
特別是對於當時的
可能發生的經濟的問題
和可能發生的衰
那麼來說的話不算很低
但是我們看過去幾個星期
其實市場進入現在這個狀態
過去幾個星期
市場是把這個left tail給砍掉了
也就是特別是
特朗普和中國談判之後
包括他最近好像接受媒體訪問的時候
還說我要去粉華
對吧
我們老大沒有理他
老大把它晾在一邊沒理他
但是表現出美國政策上面
第一個政策上面
開始往一個更加理性的狀態去轉換
政治上面有可能的情況
是被Belsent取代了Navarro的這個角色
就經濟顧問Navarro
現在他很多政策
後來沒有再實施
所以大家覺得
現在出來的可能是採掌的政策
那麼我們會認為
他的tail risk被很大程度上砍掉了
也就是說
我們不覺得
ifactive tariff會跑到12以上
有可能還會比12更低
那這個是市場
現在pricing的東西
那麼可能再捨
那麼是不是pricing
就我們認為這個定價足夠
這個是政治評論的工作了
就是說這個很難判斷的
因為特朗普這個人雙子座
也是隨時會改變自己想法
但是假設現在在12
那麼我們的fundamental是怎麼樣的
就我前幾個星期一直講的
我們fundamental是uncertain的
是不確定的
也不是說我們fundamental很強
即使你加了12%的tail of
這個對於經濟的影響是1.2
對於通脹影響可能是1.2
這個來回之後
我這個下面還有兩堂
我本來想交往幾家了
就是我們原來有的fat put和exacted put
就原來在24年年底的時候
我們美聯儲的put
美聯儲一定會救的
美聯儲put在
exacted put也在
兩個東西都在
到了那個今年3 4月份的時候
其實兩個都沒了
然後市場跌得最兇的時候
兩個都沒了
現在我們認為可能有exacted put
包括Belsand在那個
最近剛過了一個tax bill
就是那個眾議院
可能要過一個tax bill
tax bill的draft出來了
然後Belsand做了一次新聞
新聞對話
所以他當時講到的是要保持經濟增長
我們的赤字是歸因於前一任的不負責
然後但是我們現在首要目標
是要保持經濟增長
大概是這麼講的
就是我寫的東西都找不到
在這裡
對他當然是這麼講
他就說我們inherit這個債務
是從那個相當於是我繼承
從那個Biden內繼承
但是我們希望其實經濟增長更快
然後來stabilize這個東西
其實這個是一個
相對來說proviseless的一個說法
所以我們認為exacted put可能在
這個是可能
對於特朗普政府
它還是有不確定性的
但是fact put可能不在
在今年情況下可能不在
明年有可能會在
所以今年情況下可能不在
因為短期裡面有通脹因素
經濟沒有見到實體實在的往下掉的時候
那麼它不在
所以從fundamental本質上來說
它是很強不確定性的
比去年一定是弱很多
所以這個tradoff是什麼呢
就是我們現在的市場的position
變得更加light了
我們不管是看cta
這個星期其實已經加倉加了很多
有很多人加倉加過去了
那麼但是我們從那個包括cta
包括從bock control
然後加上那個hatch fund position來說的話
現在比2024年說的好很多
不管最近漲成什麼樣子
但是vix畢竟沒有回到2024年這個水平
2024年年底的時候在
特別是在trump選舉之前
vix曾經是到12的
那個是到很低的水平
包括那個quate spread都是非常非常窄的
所以現在position相對來說比較light
但是對應的是經濟基本面的不確定性
所以我會覺得在同樣估值比較高的情況下
我們往下跌的概率會大很多
雖然它的速度和這個幅度不一定會像前面這麼快
不一定會像前面我們叫做非常迅速
非常那麼猛
但是市場下跌的概率是會比去年年底要高很多的
去年年底我們說tell risk確實
就是你回到那個時點
你認為它真正下跌的概率其實沒有那麼高
我們沒有人知道它會搞出這樣的這個荒水政策來的
但是如果它不搞的話
大概率今年也不一定會下跌
但是現在來看到年底的話
你把所有的事情放在一個static不變的一個狀態裡面
那今年年底下跌的概率還是蠻大的
就是概率上來說百分比概率上來還是蠻大的
所以我們在市場上博弈的時候永遠是相當於是在賭錢
你是不同的概率不同的培率裡面去賭這個就是下注
所以現在下注我覺得是現在下注偏貴
就是偏貴為什麼偏貴
不光是從股票股票的事情我上週好像已經講過了
現在大概pricing了10倍的增長22倍批
現在的股票價錢
包括美國現在被當過的時候一天就拿回去
其實retail buying就是市場上買盤還是很重
我們在這一輪下跌
OPPO3月份4月份這一輪下跌
我覺得有一個很值得關注的事情
就是credit market在我們叫做信用市場上
就是信用債
信用在市場上
我們這一輪跌的最凶的時候
也沒有看到境外投資人
就是美國的境外投資人
就像在其他國家投資人
大規模拋售美國信用債
並沒有看到這個跡象
那麼在信用債的積差裡面
我們甚至一直看到cdx對atrix是有一個一家的
就是我們叫做quadrux pair相對來說更低一點
如果說hyg是美國的hio比較垃圾債
就信用比較低的高息債的三個b價高息債的一個指數
相當於是有一個etf
然後LQD是investment未來距的
那麼你把這個如果說是hio的intrest
就是quadrux spread把它拉出來的話
hio credit spread基本上是在280個basis point
然後在今年年初吧
然後中間的調到大概升到大概320
在最差的時候升到過500
就是在reparation在獨立率之前大概320
現在大概回到320到350的水平
那就是和reparation day之前差不多
但是這幾年以來平均的數字是450
也就是說我們現在的水平
還比起這幾年平均的時候
就這些年就從比方說
那個這10年的平均數要高
就是quadrux spread比這10年的平均數要高
那你這個定價的話
相對來說我們認為現在的
就是我們叫垃圾級的債券
或是垃圾級的公司的破產概率要更低嗎
那麼對比一下每次衰退的時候
比方說我們在這一次2018年
2019年2018年那個時候
那個2020年
像2022年這種衰退的時候
其實是要到600
然後在那個COVID的時候
其實是要到900
在那個08年09年的時候是殺得更深
所以你現在並沒有
就是說我們從那個quadrux市場上
完全沒有pricing美國會衰退
那這個事情沒有
那個Investment Grays一樣類似
那個基本上Investment Grays在120到160
然後真正衰退的時候跳到208
但是現在沒有到
就是現在這個我們叫做quadrux spread
還是相對來說比較低的
那我這個東西和股市是相對應的
就是我們認為公司破產概率更低
公司的估值更高
那麼這個背景是我們對於
經濟基本面的看法
但是經濟基本面是不確定的
就是現在定價
我覺得經濟基本面定價相對來說不高了
那這個是我覺得現在下注的
一個相對來說的問題
但是在短期裡面不太受這個影響
短期裡面不是放在mantel driven的
短期裡面是情緒絕紋
和market position絕紋
那market position相對來說
又比較light 比較輕
所以就是說現在是一個
確實是比較難以操作的一個市場
這個確實是
那從更加長期來說
我們記得我在去年有兩個比較重要的觀點
第一個就是美國國債率會一直往上跑
那個像希西弗斯推石頭一樣
你推下來這樣去
這個本質上是美國發債週期
就是美國進入一個政府債務的週期
都有可能把這東西打斷
那麼但是整個非常長期來看的話
那個我看美國利率會不停的step
因為發債週期一旦開始
覺得你這個東西跟細毒一樣
你很難停下來
但對美國來說傷害並沒有那麼大
它傷害的可能是
導致了後面一部分的inflationary
導致一部分的通脹因子
這個通脹因子也不是美國一加持
是所有受美元的人都會吃的
所以它可能也只有這個辦法
慢慢來消化這個債務
然後讓債務繼續增加
中國其實用債務週期從08年開始
所以你會看到中國債務週期開始以後
它的資產是怎麼樣子
就是製房產這個東西是怎麼樣子
所以我一直覺得美國的
就是從2023年之後的
就是COVID之後
它的債務週期開始以後
它的資產的長牛其實是非常長的
那麼在短期裡面
其實短期我就講到
上週我也收到我的美國國債的問題
美國國債10年期
今年的發債規模其實並補大的
就是我們會看
不管你今年的tax war有多少
因為這個事情是目的拿來說
美國要當歸的一個重要原樣
但是發債看DVO1的
DVO1去年發了一個別臉
今年大概750個免臉吧
750708吧
我忘了說早
但差不多就是這個下了20%到25%
708 下了20%
所以那個從發債今年的規模來說
國債壓力並沒有那麼大
就不要拒絕我的意思
我並不是覺得國債利率跑不到
不能一直往上跑
國債在更長期的時間裡面
一定是一個非常明確的Steepen的交易
就是Steepen的意思就是
長期長端減短端這個價差要變開的
然後它的本質是你一直要發債
所以發債的力量很大
然後讓你的短長期債
其實維持在一個比較高的位置
而且你發債比較多以後
你會有一些通脹的力量影響在那裡
這和關稅沒有關系
本身你發錢
財政政策引起通脹是非常直接的
所以會有一些通脹因子
同時的話你經濟基本面上來說
你的短期的力率
總究是要慢慢下去的
所以Steepen是一個相對的說
更長期是確定的事情
但是不要誤解我意思
我說的是今年的發債量其實並不大
美國也沒有 maturity war
就是債務的叫做債務到期的上限
那就說回到我們這周末
討論很多次的那個目的
把美國當歸的這個事情的影響
我覺得這件事情其實分幾個方面來看
就是第一個目的
當歸美國這個東西說到這個
我們叫做那個債務就是到期
今年大量的債務到期
就萬一的到期是不是一個問題
這是第一個
第二個就是當歸美國之後
會產生什麼樣的後果
然後我們可以回顧第三個就是
當時S&P和Finch也把美國給當歸國
那當時當歸以後
市場做出了什麼樣的反應
然後這些事情在 physical policy
在那個會不會影響美國現在產生政策
因為它後面
我們講到就是周末一個最大的利好
就是Belsand認為333這件事情
不是那麼堅持的
就是我3%的赤字
這個333不再這麼堅持我赤字的規模
把赤字歸結於拜登政府
然後說我要繼續印錢
那我要繼續發債
這個是對經濟基本面影相對來說
比較利好的消息
所以會不會影響它的 physical policy
這是一個問題
第一個我覺得除了我這件事情不存在的
因為為什麼你是簡單看了9萬億要發債
你沒有去看這個發債背後
它是發了短債還是長債
所以我們看這個真正來說
發債可能會造成更大壓力的是
就是有票息的債權
就是兩年以上的債權
就是Build
就是我們叫短期債
這個東西就相當於
我們叫Money Market Instrument
相當於貨幣生產工具
這個多多少都是發不出去
都是沒有問題的
也不說我之前說到的美元
是我們現在所有金融底層的
就是我們C++語言
所以我們所有的語言
都是美元上的基礎上的
你finch再把美國當過
你哪怕搭配到一個Single C或者是D
你把它說到default都可以
但是目的你把它搭配到什麼
你目的的員工的工資用美元發的
所以你永遠逃不開美元
所以真正的這個東西
沒有特別大意
就是說本質上我們的底層是美元協
但是有沒有一個Maturity Ward
甚至連Maturity Ward都沒有
就是這個稻期的牆都沒有
因為你如果這是我們每個月的稻期
但是你把每個月的稻期
長債和短債去掉的話
這個Builds就是這個顏色的
深色的就是短債
然後那個橙色就是長債
所以你會看到其實長債
如果你把直把長債拉開來的話
美國Trustry財政部
對於長債發行管理
基本上還是非常穩定的
也就是說我們會看到
每個月它發行的長債是非常穩定
不存在什麼今年要發9萬億
然後發不出去的問題
根本不可能
就是它的長債和短債的管理
相對來說
保持整個市場的供需非常穩定
然後那個9萬億的長債
中間有很大一部分是Builds
然後就一個月或者是一個星期
這種債權作為貨幣市場工具
在所有銀行
在所有金融體系裡面
當成美元現鈔在用
當成美元現鈔
再付卡拉主
再付保證金
那麼說到這個東西
對實體
就是說美國借債這個實體
不影響一萬
那麼Dongry本身這件事情
會有什麼樣的後果
其實理論上
Dongry會有很嚴重的後果
就是說因為Dongry的
它影響了並不是說美元信用出現問題
債券信用出現問題了
而是說有的時候
我比方說我Pose讓債券
我Pose卡拉主
我給出去抵押品
給到比方說
那個我做一筆演生品交易
因為所有的金融的本質是借錢
是槓桿
那槓桿的本質
就是說我能夠槓桿比率多少
我的抵押品是拿什麼東西可以抵押
那為什麼美元沒有問題
因為所有金融的本質
是可以拿美元去做抵押
不是拿人民幣可以做抵押
對吧
但是你如果拿張美國債券
三個A的債券去做抵押
你的Hackard基本是沒有的
應該是100%
那個國債應該是101
就這個樣子
Hackard100%
但是如果你拿美元抵押是100%
對吧
但是如果你的信用評級被改變了
那你拿美國國債去抵押
Hackard有可能會變化
就是根據不同的CSE的協議
根據那個不同的抵押品的協議
在這種情況下
可能會改變他的Hackard
那麼這個問題會直接導致
市場Leverage的改變
這個是一個相對來說
看上去比較嚴重的問題
因為以前S&P當歸美國以後
Death Sealing
應該在2011年
因為應該是Death Sealing的事情當歸
Acquity
當時英文美國政府也關掉了
股票跌了20%
但是當時債券漲了20%
因為你有一些抵押規則被改變了
所以你要去買債
你要去搶這個債券
反正債券避險
反而被漲
但是Finch當歸的時候
在COVID的時候
那時候其實配合了很多的美國穿水
在當歸之後立馬公布了
我要發行大量的短期債和酷炮炮
所以當時是股債雙跌了
股票跌完之時
然後加上因為有COVID的影響
然後那個TLT
TLT長債的那個長債一天跌了17%
所以這一次怎麼變化
就是對市場影響
我們不確定
但是這那兩次
因為美國當歸以後
其實有很多銀行
都修改了克蘭茹的規定
就是說如果當美國Trash Rea
國債需要有Hacket
去做抵押品
需要Hacket的時候
那一定是市場去適應美國國債
而不是美國國債去適應市場
就是說如果投資銀行高盛
它需要比如說中國被當歸的
你拿中國國債
或者人民幣來抵押
它可以給你5%的Hacket
然後讓你不接受你這個抵押品
但是當美國國債被當歸以後
只有高盛區
就是所有投資銀行高盛或低了
去那個銀河美國國債
而不是反過來的
所以我們這個趨勢
我們在過去看到過
S&P當歸的時候發生過
那Moodie當歸
那個Finch當歸的時候也發生過
Moodie當歸不會是例外
所以你不用去幹美國被當歸成什麼樣子
他當歸唐Single A Single C
他的國債
Claddle Hacket還是1801億
他甚至可以去美聯儲去接100%
然後再拿現金過來的
所以對市場影響是什麼
就像Belson說的
是零沒有什麼影響
對情緒是有影響
但是對於債券市場本質是沒有影響
這個是我對那個
對於Moodie當歸和美國9萬億國債的
這個事情的一個分析
然後另外再加上去說的
就是美國債務是不是很嚴重
這個脫開講一個問題
美國債務是不是很嚴重
美國債務為中國好很多很多
因為債務你不光是看Public Sector of debt
對吧
你還看Private Sector of debt
你私營部門債務利率利息的
能反來學Sector of Corporate的這個利息
就是說佔他Profit的比率
其實你看這些年一直在下降
就是我們會看到美國公司的Balance
是非常非常強
就公司的Profitability非常強
Modern很強
以至於他利息收入
就你不管利息升多高
那是利息支出在他的盈利比率
中間非常低
第二個整個公司Copy level
能反來
這個是美國那個
Louis and the Fed的那個公佈數據
就是說整個能反來Sector of corporate
debt security and loan
佔他佔整個GDP的比率
佔美國GDP的比率
所以你會看到私營部門的
債務總債務
他在2020年初一直在下降
但公有部門上升了一些
但是私營部門的下降還是很大
美國也私營部門為主的
所以我們雖然會一直在說
美國政府欠債欠債欠債
但是你會看到美國企業
公司盈利很好
然後企業債務在下降
這個叫倉富漁民
中國和美國走了
完全不同的經濟路徑
然後就是directly opposite
完全正好相反的經濟反應
那在私營部門有沒有
比方說我們剛剛看到
國債方面來說
國家是沒有那個 maturity war
對吧
沒有那個倒棄牆的
那在私營部門有沒有倒棄牆的
一樣沒有
這是高層整理的數據
我覺得不是很清楚
Investment grade
25年
那個這個 hi-yield
這個25年
其實倒棄都不是
就是不是說現在
馬上有大規模倒棄
所以美國債務情況
我不覺得很嚴重
所以這個東西
你在企業端
個人端
其實來說這個債務情況
都不是特別嚴重
所以我覺得
就是沒有特別大的必要
去擔心美國債務
不管他那個
Belson怎麼說怎麼做
他今天是重新開始
如果他重新開始債務周期
那美國現在就是
中國的2009年
2010年
而不是說是中國的2018年
這個債務情況
比你們早很多年
好很多
所以他有很多時間
可以去走這個債務的路徑的
那就是一個
資產的泡沫的周期
如果說Belson的現在的態度
是不想去搞這個東西
或者是他通過
by the way
他即使通過這個東西
是需要時間的
他不是說我這個
Tax bill出來以後馬上可以過的
他現在是draft出來
然後他還要過
下一球要過眾議員
然後接著要過參議員
參議員能不能過
是一個問號
因為參議員他的票
其實只多一票
那個參議員過幾個月
所以我上週講的這個時間差
就是說我可能會發生
那個衰退的時間差
和他的一些
Tax bill的這個
我們叫做減稅
或者是用錢的
這個時間差還是存在的
但是我們從更加長期來看
就是整個市場
如果他放錢的話
他有還是有很大餘地去放錢
那麼最後說到一個問題
就是我們可能花個三五分鐘
今天多說幾句吧
就是美元走弱這個問題
US dollar
dollar weakening trend
是不是維持
那個從flow上來看
上兩週
其實大部分的那個
我們叫做
dollar shop position
其實平倉比較多
就是說我們沒有看到很多的
這個真正的去做多美元的投算
更多的是
shop position
我們之前做空的平倉
也是我們之前講過
到了暑假的時候
美元走弱的話
這個趨勢會稍微停一下
因為Hatch fund總是會把這些投資
慢慢給清掉
那real money hedge
我們是明確的看到的增加
而且我覺得有一個明確的趨勢
有個很強的趨勢
就是說我們會覺得那些亞洲的國家
包括韓國
包括中國
包括臺灣這些地方
它很有可能
它的貨幣原來關聯度很差的過
貨幣會關聯度變得很強
而且對美國有一種一下子走強的
就是現在特朗普把很多的關稅的談判
介入到這個
把貨幣介入到關稅談判當中去了
所以其實亞洲的不少的國家
其實包括日本在內
這些國家的貨幣
其實在美國眼裡全部是被低估了
就是他們故意壓低貨幣
然後對美出口
那麼在關稅談判中間
臺灣其實是個先例
就是臺灣是個很好例子
因為臺灣大概有個1.5萬億的
private and public sector的這個美元的池
就美元資產
1萬億美元是private sector
就是個人啊公司啊這些池油
然後0.5千億大概是國家吧
就是public sector的那種
那從舉個例子
他們基本不Hatch
從那個5年前Hatch ratio
在保險公司裡面大概是20%Hatch ratio
然後現在Hatch ratio340吧
那麼在美國
現在有可能美國強制臺灣要去把貨幣
比方說變強以後
那麼很有可能發生的事情
就是原來不Hatch的人要回頭去對撞
這個事情也有可能會發生在韓國
也有可能會發生日本
所以原來是競爭性貨幣
就是我的貶值和升值
這貨幣是有競爭性的
特別是比方說韓圓
日圓這些有競爭性的貨幣
它非常有可能會變成一個方向去走
然後往那個美元走弱的方向
它很有可能會有一個jump risk
就是一下子跳野式的增長的方向
所以這個我們是可以在
那個亞洲體系的貨幣中間觀察
然後亞洲體系另外一個比較確信的
一些交易的點是這樣子
貨幣中間有很多政治的因素
但是利率這個政治因素相對來說比較少
我們看到美國的需求變少的同時
所有亞洲國家出虎性的國家
這個包括中國在內都要印錢
因為他們都非常依賴美國出口
就是美國經濟走弱或者軟著弱
這個確定性還是越來越高的
就是說我們說到經濟的不確定性
那至少說不會走這麼強吧
不會像去年這樣Fundamental走了很強
所以在軟著弱的過程中
亞洲國家都會受到傷害
比方說韓國第一季度GDP已經變負了
那個韓國像比如說韓國
它降氣的概率是很大的
所以receive a swap
然後或者是那個做空它的長端利率
我覺得這個這個確定性和趨勢
還是相對來說比較強
從利率上來說
這因為我原來是乾利率的
所以我就說幾個可能利率上的一些看法
好吧今天我多說了一話
然後留一點時間給大家聽一會吧